ricoh ville et chercheur à l'iris
spécialiste de l'iran
bonsoir avoue thierry coville merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france donc l'iran qui demandent qu'à
demander à rejoindre cette organisation
de coopération de shanghai en 2008 c'est
désormais chose faite
en quoi cette adhésion elle marque un
tournant pour l'iran mais aussi à les
membres de cette organisation
ben c'est comme vous l'a dit c'est une
alliance très important ça on va dire
c'est c'est une alliance qui regroupe
quand même de gros poids lourds de la
planète c'est dire la chine et la russie
avec un son de pays d'asie centrale
et l'iran a été observateur dans cette
alliance qui est une arche de cours à
caractère sécuritaire quand même qui par
les questions de sécurité donc
que l'iran soit acceptée dans cette
erreur je pense que c'est une victoire
diplomatique pour l'iran parce que je
crois qu'il y avait des pays comme le
tadjikistan qui refusaient
l'adhésion d'iran pour un coût du
soutien de l'iran l'opposition islamique
gouvernement tadjik m'enfin là ça s'est
calmé donc c'était une victoire
diplomatique pour l'iran et on voit se
constituer
on va dire un pôle
sécuritaire concurrentiel quelque part
à ce pool occidentales auxquelles il
faisait référence dans votre journal
alors c'est une adhésion de l'iran qui a
été saluée par vladimir poutine
pourquoi l'art la russie se félicite
autant de cette adhésion
bon alors moi je suis pas dans le secret
des dieux mais d'après ce que j'ai
entendu
la russie milite depuis un certain temps
pour que pour que l'iran devienne membre
de cette organisation
donc c'est aussi une victoire pour la
russie
je pense qu'aussi d'après ce qu'on
entend dire c'est le fait pour la russie
d'intégrer l'iran qui est quand même
alors c'est pas il ne sera pas une
puissance du niveau de la russie la
chine mais pas une grande puissance
régionale ça permet à la russie d'avoir
un partenaire de poids qui permet de
limiter l'influencé de la chine dans
cette organisation donc très clairement
si on peut dire que c'est aussi une
victoire pour la russie alors justement
un mot peut être sûr
l'émission de cette organisation de
coopération de shanghai son poids sur la
scène internationale également
alors pour l'instant d'après ce que je
sais ils discutent surtout de
coopération dans le domaine sécuritaire
ce qui est important parce que il ya
quand même toulal tous là toute la lutte
contre les mouvements radicaux
islamiques qui intéresse à des degrés
divers tous ces pays je crois pas que de
gros efforts faits en termes de faim
de réalisations concrètes en termes de
coopération économique mais ça pourrait
changer et on
voit très bien que derrière il ya des
enjeux très importants
si on prend le cas de l'iran très
clairement ils sont en pleine
négociation comme vous savez pour
éventuellement que les états unis
reviennent dans l'accord sur le
nucléaire de cet accord de 2015 si
jamais cessé ses négociations échouent
on voit très bien que un scénario un
deuxième scénario pour les rangs c'est
de développer la coopération économique
avec la russie et la chine très
clairement l'appartenance et ce type
d'organisation permettrait donnerait un
cadre à l'iran pour développer ses
relations économiques et commerciales
avec la russie la chine ou je vous dis
on en est qu'au début mais envoie un
impôt pour l'instant sécuritaire et qui
pourrait devenir un pôle économique
commercial qui serait pendant qu'ils
seraient on veut dire un opposant on
veut dire ou pour l'occident calme
on apprend justement cette adhésion au
moment où les états unis ont conclu
mon plus le contrat du siècle entre la
france et l'australie avec leurs alliés
le royaume uni
comment justement les états unis vont
réagir puisque on sait que joe biden il
ne souhaite pas voir la chine tomber
dans le giron russe et cette adhésion
avec les rend aussi ça doit aussi
provoqué l'ire de washington on imagine
oui mais alors
les commandes hier quelque part les
américains récolte un petit peu ce
qu'ils ont semé parce que je me rappelle
très bien savait il ya je retiens il ya
quelques mois on a annoncé la signature
d'un accord de 25 ans entre l'iran et la
chine donc un accord de coopération
économique et stratégique mais à ce
moment là même aux états unis même on a
dit ben oui mais il faut rappeler quand
même que les états unis rappeler de
nouveau et sont sortis dans la halle de
l'accord sur nucléaire en mai 2018
qu'ils auraient imposé des larmes
sanctions contre l'iran il ya des
difficultés pour qu'il revienne dans cet
accord donc je dire on ne peut pas
reprocher à l'iran de chercher des
soutiens géopolitique des soutiens
économiques et donc de passer un accord
avec la chine et de rejoindre sète
comment dire cet accord de shanghai qui
lui donne quand même quelque part une
qui renforce ses liens stratégiques
et un militaire avec la russie et la
chine parce que justement les états unis
on appliquait une politique de pression
maximale sous trump est quelque part by
donne pour l'instant n'a pas valoir je
sais de politique donc pour elle pour
répondre à vos questions effectivement
les états sont pas contents mais quelque
part les récoltent ce qu'ils ont semé
avec la stratégie de trump qui a
consisté à sortir de la corde en mai
2010huit l'accord sur duclair de juillet
2015 merci beaucoup à vous à thierry
coville chercheur à l'iris spécialiste
de l'iran